let's go next to our caller from the
nine five six area code who's calling
today from nine five six
this is Rakhi Raina from the rockier a
no-show hey rocky what's going on um I
want to point out two different things
first of all I'm a big fan i watch your
show I'm also a small youtuber and I
first things first one thing I know I'm
a conservative I'm a Native American
conservative who has a little show but I
noticed that your kryptonite is Donald
Trump does that make sense no it doesn't
what do you mean my kryptonite I think
that you're a pretty level-headed person
as a conservative there's a lot of
things that I would have very difficulty
disagreeing with you except when it
comes to Donald Trump I think that he
cloud your judgment because he's so
arrogant so what's an example of that um
I feel like you don't know you put out
various videos on YouTube they're like
four or five minutes yes we publish
videos to YouTube yeah okay you tend to
nitpick on little insignificant things
that I know add up but in the broader or
for example when you were on Jesse Lee
Peterson show yeah he asked you a
question
you it's not that you didn't answer he
just basically said well you don't like
Trump and I could tell you he really got
a rise out of you what did I say how did
he get a rise out of me um you said no
that's not true you're not letting me
speak and then he kicked you off the
show but before he did that is basically
um you couldn't you he asked you what
are the good things that he did what are
some of the good things that he did and
then he said um no matter what I
remember I listed the I listed the
things yeah okay look for example for
border security though well what I mean
to me that's a pretty rational what's
your objections to that I mean I don't
know if you have any listeners that live
on the border it's fairly dangerous
what's my objection to what I'm like
down the wall the
a waste of money and it doesn't actually
deal with the reason people are trying
to come here nor visa overstays which
are a bigger problem than people
crossing the wall physically okay and so
okay for example another thing I know
this is I don't want to be disrespectful
but you're Argentinian correct I'm sorry
I'm what I'm Argentinean yes yes I am
okay now would you say you come from
like a middle-class background or an
upper-middle class background no my
family left Argentina cuz we had no
money and the economy imploded so we
came to the US with nothing and then my
dad he had to go back through you know
he was a doctor in Argentina which
sounds luxurious but it's not trust me
doctors in Argentina in 1989 were not
making any money
he had to re-establish himself as a
doctor here in the US and I guess like
10 or 12 years after we were here he
finally started making you know a good
salary but no I mean the our first 10
years here in the US were not
particularly easy I guess the point I'm
trying to make is that it just seems
that the the the majority of social
media personalities on YouTube or just
in general they come from a very middle
class upper middle class background so I
didn't come from that but who are you
thinking of well for example I'm no
disrespect you know but that's not the
case my family left Argentina with no
money and that said that so we figured
out that doesn't apply I mean have you
ever lived in a dangerous neighborhood
you heard gunshots at night did you live
I live in Massachusetts so Massachusetts
as a state is there's very few parts of
Massachusetts where you're hearing
gunshots at night I just don't know what
point you're trying to make well I'm
trying to make is that a lot of
progressives that I see they don't
really have I mean they want something
but they've never been there advocating
for people that come from a struggle and
I and I think when you overcome
adversity by yourself on your own you
look at things a lot differently yes but
is there
like isn't that isn't that good don't we
want people who can say hey even if I
don't need something myself this is
still a good thing for the government to
do because I'm thinking about other
people like that's called empathy that
seems like a good thing well I mean yeah
it's thousand 19 and empathy gonna get
anything accomplished with all due
respect what gets things accomplished is
hard work I mean a strong work ethic and
logic and I know when it comes to
charging the person in the world but
when you would disagree with me that
he's gotten a lot done whether good or
bad yes yes he's gotten a lot done if
you say good or bad he's gotten a lot
done that's bad I agree with that I mean
that's what I'm saying he's ruffled a
lot of feathers and but is that good
what's the best sometimes done rocky
what's the best thing Trump's done well
Norman you got it I'm a veteran so when
he got into office one of the first
things that he did was didn't he give
veterans more money for disability I
don't know you tell me is that what he
did when did he do that yeah yeah he did
he did and then he did again recently
he's also took money that was allocated
for for military and he listed that
recently and put it into border security
or listen to the yeah it's it's even
legal all right rocky listen I guess
you've made a number of different points
and I appreciate you calling it ok ok
can you do me one one favorite it's like
I said I have my own YouTube channel and
even though I'm a conservative I'm a
die-hard fan i watch your show
can you just say because I have you on
my microphone can you say thank you for
watching the rocky earth I'm saying no
idea anything about your show or what it
is that I would be endorsing so that's
not something I can do today the YouTube
channel if you watch my show I don't I'm
not like what are those alright um you
know just it's a satirical show but
alright alright good very good rocky
thank you so much for the call I very
much appreciate it